we're four days from the total solar
eclipse that will shroud parts of the
u.s. in darkness for more than two and a
half minutes an estimated 12 million
people live in the path and an estimated
88 million live within 200 miles of it
many towns hope some of those 88 million
will visit and bring their tourism
dollars with them Adriana Diaz is in
Chicago with the story of st. Joseph
Missouri one community ready to sell
mementos of the Eclipse
Adriana good morning good morning as you
can see Eclipse souvenirs are a big
Eclipse mania has taken over towns like
Saint Joseph for 2 minutes and 38
seconds of the Eclipse Monday st.
Joseph's has been preparing and selling
merchandise for months the total eclipse
a rare celestial event has excited
astronomers and sky watchers across the
world well I've got a two-car garage
there's never been a car in and capture
the attention of some hoping to cash in
p/j Joyce makes t-shirts in her garage
and in 38 years in the business she's
never been this busy how are you
handling all this demand I've put in
some very very long errors I have put in
some 18-hour days she's been churning
out Eclipse t-shirts one at a time by
hand I have two designs of this shirt
one is with cocktails and one was with
them are you planning on having a
cocktail on Monday or two the bulk of
Joyce's shirts will come here to the st.
Joseph Visitors Bureau she estimates she
has made between eight and ten thousand
for them when did you first realize the
Eclipse was coming right over a st. Joe
we received our first email about four
years ago and the gentleman put in all
caps do you realize that st. Joseph's is
on the path of totality for the
solar clip beth carmichael is with the
visitor's bureau where she says eclipse
merchandise is in hot demand this is our
merchandise room we have been selling
t-shirts solar eclipse glasses proceeds
from the sales are going to benefit
nonprofit museums in st. Joseph and
Carmichael says orders are coming in
from around the globe it's really
exciting because so many people are
gonna see our name all over the world
a total eclipse is going to follow this
exact same pattern this city of about
seventy six thousand there's also home
to the National Pony Express museum
commemorating the famous 19th century
mail service they got into the Eclipse
act after realizing that the path of
totality followed part of the Pony
Express trail they have hats ornaments
and of course t-shirts with the theme
where two trails cross how does this
merchandise help the museum well you
know you always look for fundraising
throughout the year but when you can
bring in something else and bring in
another five to seven to $8,000 that
takes care of one half of our bills for
a month it goes far beyond just t-shirts
at this local gift shop they have things
like Eclipse themed platters drink
cozies and your very own Eclipse soap
scenes like this are playing out across
the country visit any town along the
path of totality and you're bound to
find businesses with similar Eclipse
themed swag but if you're not on the
path the US Postal Service issued these
eclipse stamps which changed from dark
to light when exposed to heat despite
all the excitement surrounding the
Eclipse some will be glad when it's all
over so the best thing about the 21st
it's going to be the day after that
would be the 22nd because it's been a
very long couple weeks here lately
nobody knows exactly how many people
will travel to the towns and cities in
the path of totality but Nora let's just
hope they're enough souvenirs to go
around lots of souvenirs needed Adrianna
thank you so much for that and we're
gonna bring you all the best views of
the solar eclipse Monday that's in a CBS
News special report you can watch it
right here and on our streaming network
cbsn at 1:00 p.m. Eastern no central so
for some reason you can't see it guess
what we've got it for you here at CBS
that's what we do that's what we do yeah
we keep everybody covered they need to
be there join us yeah join us but I love
that they're cashing in on this I hope
they make a lot of money so a lot of
t-shirts and sunglasses well it's a good
opportunity that's right kids to learn
about science and it only happens once
every gazillion years so go for it